[Music]
how many times have you cheated on her
eight years uh eight times and then
never again after that i've decided it's
time that you know i confess this to her
regardless of which way it goes i'll
tell you this what you did was stupid
and it was selfish and it was hurtful
and you know that so i'm not gonna
applaud you for what you did but i'm
gonna applaud you for what you're doing
[Music]
what's up what's up this is john the
doctor john deloney show
coming at you live
from nashville tennessee except we're
not live
and i'm actually in a suburb of
nashville so in franklin so most of the
things i just said at the intro were not
true but this is the john d'alone show
talking about mental health marriage
parenting relationships all the stuff
uh back to school time everything and uh
we are excited that you're i'm excited
man i'm just i'm just i'm excited that's
kind of a dramatic i'm just so grateful
i'm just so grateful that um you all
keep showing up and listening telling
your friends
uh if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
or go to 1-844-693-3291
ask a-s-k
um all right let's go to stevo steve in
charleston south carolina what's up
steve
hello
hello
can you hear me i can can you hear me
i can how are you doing today
outstanding man
you're not from the southern united
states are you
what's that
you're not from the southern united
states are you
i'm not originally man you've picked it
up well done well done
i still talk like a texan i'm trying to
trying to get it out of there hey so
what's up man how can i help
it's kind of the first time i'm ever
saying it out loud so just
bear with me for a minute um you got it
so in the beginning part of the
relationship between me and my current
life
i was unfaithful
and
at one point i ended up leaving because
i accepted
the fact that i was never going to tell
her and i was just going to hold it in
and just
never break her with that
and i just let the guilt make me leave
the relationship
um
later on down the line i made another
selfish act of coming back in
um
with the illusion that
as long as i am the man that i intend to
be and plan to be and want to be for her
um
that this could just be a dark secret
that gets hidden and
here we are years later and it's uh
eaten away at me and
i've decided it's time that you know i
confess this to her regardless of which
way it goes
um and i was just wondering some tips on
how i can best
convey this to her and support her
during this hard conversation
um
one thanks for saying it out loud man
thanks for saying out loud thank you um
i'm the first person you ever told that
uh yeah
wow
um
i'm reading the game around because
you're [ __ ]
uh i started listening to you a few
weeks ago and uh it started eating up
and eating up and firing up and firing
up inside of me and i i finally realized
that i can't be who i want to be
holding this secret in yeah and it's
also kept you from being the person
you've wanted to be all the time in the
past too right just find yourself here
yeah absolutely um i'm reading between
the lines here
um
did you cheat under where you were
dating too
like you you left you didn't leave your
marriage
it was pretty much from
uh
the point where we started dating to
uh up until i left years ago
okay and when you say you left does that
mean you just broke up with her while
y'all were dating or you left your
marriage
marriage okay
um
how long have you all been married
uh
i mean since we're 18.
not super helpful because i don't know
how old you are now
oh uh sorry about uh seven eight years
okay
how many times have you cheated on her
eight years
uh
in the first
three
uh eight times and then never again
after that
so in the first three years was the same
person
no
tell me about people you're cheating
with
uh
i mean was it people you work with
girlfriends people from craigslist
people
that
on occasion that i went to high school
with
um and then
just random people you meet over the
internet
okay
what happened three years ago that you
said no more and you've gone five years
from
uh
violating your marriage
uh i realized that you know those
actions were
part of a
were being selfish of me and just kind
of feeding into a selfish behavior that
i've had for a while and
i didn't enjoy it i didn't enjoy
being selfish every bit of it came with
guilt but i couldn't seem to
keep myself on the straight path and
the illusion of
not seeing not ever having this girl
again and
losing the opportunity to have a family
with her
it kind of just
made me think that i can hide this
secret and continue on the straight and
narrow and it would be like it never was
and never happened so here i am
we'll get to how do you tell
okay there's an important there's an
important way to do that a right way to
do that and there's a couple of terrible
wrong ways to do it
here's my concern
your reason for quitting
cheating on your wife
is still utterly selfish
you have not
you've you don't want to blow this with
her
you want to have a family with her
you want to stop feeling guilty
and when i haven't heard from you is
i destroyed the life of somebody that i
love
and there's an
empathy
there's a submission there's a take in a
knee
while somebody sits above you
and saying i'm sorry because i've just
thrown a grenade in everything you think
you know
and i don't hear that in you
i may have i mean maybe it's
the first time i'm saying it because
that's what's in my mind
okay uh
that's why you know it hasn't occurred
again and that's why
i've gotten to the point of feeling
as if i need to confess about this
because
i i mean everything we've built and the
person that she thinks she's with is is
wrapped around an entire lie that
would change
everything from
you know our whole entire relationship
okay
so here's here's kind of the mechanics
moving forward okay i want you to think
of this um
the the way i was trained to do death
notifications by dr andy young this
guy's
a super important man to me uh brilliant
man
gave me the line facts are your friends
when you're having hard conversations
i've also been a part of having to let
employees go
um having to tell people that their kids
have passed away like like my whole
career has been hard conversations and i
did it wrong for a long time
and
until dr young gave me some pretty clear
guidance i'm going to pass that guidance
from him through me on to you okay
what's about to happen
is the death of her life
okay
you're about to put a period at the end
of everything she thinks she knows and
there'll be a before and after in her
life okay why am i telling you that i
want you to treat it that way
and when you treat it that way facts are
your friends
so here's what that means
way
less than you think you need to
the moment you sit down and say this is
a heavy conversation her heart's going
to start beating fast and she's going to
have some idea because you did leave at
some point right
yes um is there any chance she knows
about this and has chosen to not think
about it
uh
i think so i feel as if there's not a
hundred percent
trust there
and we're kind of just in a charade yeah
she pretends to believe me
because when i came back she you know
she hasn't had any inklings so she chose
kind of the
forget the past but that doesn't also
give me her full trust
a lot of times people will
yeah completely undeserving and well in
the same way that you buried part of
your life she's buried part of hers so
that we can maintain and just keep
heading forward
right and we think that if we uncover
this it's going to be worse and what you
find out over time is no the longer that
secret stays buried the more those
secrets are become infected right
and then it becomes less about you
cheated on me which is huge
you cheated on me multiple times
you made me unsafe you slapped people
off the internet and made me unsafe
to
was
christmas even real was thanksgiving
right so it it it be it begins to erode
everything right
so
um talk way less than you think
be very specific and very clear what i
mean by that
um
not
um i just
there were some times when i experienced
unfaithfulness no
when we were dating on seven different
occasions i cheated on you
i had sex with other people
then we were married the first three
years of our marriage i had sex with
eight different people
or i had sex with four different people
two times each
i have not slept with anybody else i've
not cheated on you either physically or
emotionally in eight years i don't mean
five years
you see what i'm saying that's specific
and then there's a period at the end of
that sentence
not and i know it's going to break your
heart and because here's the thing all
that explaining all of the
she is going to be in full fight or
flight
her ability to process and rationally
think through and let's talk that will
be over
it will be about survival
okay
so that's number one um number two
do
not
lie
till all of the truth
okay
if we're gonna go there let's let's just
go there is there a chance that any of
these people were her friends or
something that's gonna be even more
explosive on top of the already
explosive
no uh
just
nope okay
um
okay so don't lie and number three
here's what i did
here's what i'm doing
and i'm at your mercy now
okay
she gets to speak into what healing will
look like if there's going to be healing
okay
so here's what i did i cheated on you
period here's what i'm doing now i
haven't done anything for five years i
don't have facebook anymore i deleted
instagram because i'm not talking to
people on the internet here's the steps
i've taken
and i number three i know i've hurt you
deeply
and
i know it's gonna take time for us to
heal
and what i can tell you is i'm sorry and
i'm willing to do whatever it takes
that's the last thing i'm gonna say
okay
and she might say why what happened what
was going on
i think it's important in that moment to
say
i want to stay in this conversation and
not go back yet
i'm sorry i violated our marriage i'm
sorry you deserved better than that and
i'm sorry
and i've made steps that it will never
happen again but i know i've got a long
way to go i want you to keep bringing it
back to the present back to the present
back to the present okay
okay
here's the last thing i'll tell you
um
i i i say we're in the john wick um
generation
of people who watch a lot of movies and
they're like if dude if that ever
happened to me you know what i would do
and i always laugh and i'm like you have
no idea what you would do
all right like if that bad guy came in
here and started shooting you know what
i would do
you would probably 98 of the world would
duck and run and that's not a bad thing
you would duck a run right
um
you you have no idea what her response
will be even though you have played it
out in your head
and i want you to be at peace with the
immediate reaction and then understand
this is gonna unfold for a while okay
what that means is this she might say
get out
get out
and
i think the wise thing to do would be to
stand up and say i love you i'm sorry
maybe you have a letter written and you
put it right down there and then you
leave
okay
she may want to talk and talk and talk
and talk i think that's not super wise
but also some people just processed that
way like i said keep bringing it back to
the present back to the present back to
the present
if you take a break let's take a 30
minute break let's take an hour break
and then we can talk about the past
um that might be a wise thing to do and
then you can kind of talk start talking
about other things but
she may tell you to get out and she may
file for divorce monday
and she may tell you to get out and she
doesn't want to talk to you she won't
return your text won't turn your calls
and then she'll call you back in a week
or she may say
man steve i knew this i knew
i knew
and now you'll have some healing to
begin
right or she may say i'm not leaving you
you're not getting rid of me but we've
got a lot right you see what i'm saying
you have no idea what the response is
gonna be even though you think you know
it's gonna be are you at peace with that
i
yeah
uh no but yeah um that's a good answer
actually yeah that's a great answer it's
something that i've accepted that i will
have to deal with you know because it's
the consequence of my actions um
so yes and no dude that's some that's
some brave ownership there where'd you
learn that because that's new for you
just
uh
i mean a lot of it probably came from
listen to these last few weeks and
really reflecting back on my life um
and realizing a lot of the hurtful
things that i've done that
you know i can't can't take back but can
own up to him now and and move forward
being the person that i want to be
that's awesome i mean that literally is
the only step you got right is to own
what happened and then move on
um
do not
don't don't don't don't please i'm
smiling right now don't do this
don't say hey i've been listening to
this podcast for the last few weeks and
i realized i need to tell you something
because what that will do is that will
diminish the last eight years of
deception into
well this guy i listened to told right
um
this will be and remember what i said
earlier the more you talk about you
and what you've been experiencing
it diminishes the
apology it diminishes this moment
because this moment's going to be about
her
right this this coming clean is going to
be about her you're going to benefit
from it right you're going to walk
taller and you're going to sleep deeper
than you have in a while but you might
be doing it on a friend's couch
are you prepared for her just to say get
out and file for divorce
uh
it terrifies me but
of course you know i it's a possibility
that like i said i just
have to accept as
a possibility
what do you think she's gonna say
i don't know um
i have two versions
in my mind the
the
you know like you said i knew
i didn't fully know but i know now
and you know how do we move forward
and then the other is that's your
fantasy response right
yeah
and then the more realism comes down to
you
you know maybe not kicking me out but
we need to figure out you know what the
next steps are for this to end
i just you have this like fantasy she's
like
go get some beers and some enchiladas
and we're going to talk about this and
we'll figure it out right all right
probably not hey we just got a dream
yes
um
uh
i'll tell you this what you did was
stupid and it was selfish and it was
hurtful and you know that right i agree
yes sir um what you're doing now is
brave and honest and you're heading off
into uncharted water
and um so i'm not gonna applaud you for
what you did but i'm gonna applaud you
for what you're doing okay
uh sir that's a brave i'm proud of you
i've come to believe over the last five
or six years especially last three or
four my own marriage
secrets kill they destroy everything and
then as i've looked at the physiology
and biology of secrets they're so
destructive
and so i think you're wise i think
you're wise for your personal health
your relationship if your marriage and
most importantly for that sweet woman
that you're married to
um also dude i make no illusions about
relationships have two peop two players
okay
the time for yeah but you and that will
come in counseling on the back end of
this okay
this will be about you taking ownership
of what you've done um have you read my
new book
i have not okay hang on the line i'll
send you a free copy okay and
ironically the name of the book is own
your past change your future and that's
you right yes sir like here's where we
are and i gotta own what happened and
then we gotta make some plans for moving
forward
um will you do me a favor and reach out
to me when this when and let me know how
it goes
yes sir i will okay um you know what i'm
thinking here as i'm about to hang up
here but
i think it would be wise to hand write a
letter and put it in an envelope and
seal it
and um
give it to her
because she's going to go into fight or
flight when you tell her this stuff
and
um
when people did the letter b
just like just
basically what i would be saying to her
out loud no
this is the letter is more i love you
and i screwed up
it's gonna be less specific you don't
need to say in the letter i i did i had
sex with eight different people you
don't want to say that
say i understand that it hurts you
deeply
and i understand that you're gonna feel
like you're crazy and you're gonna feel
like the last eight years of your life
have been a lie the last 10 or 12 years
of your life have been a lie
and while it all hasn't been a lie i do
understand it
and that you'll go to your grave um
heartbroken that you broke her heart
and you're asking for forgiveness and
you're willing to do what it takes to
move forward together
okay
um but there's something tangible about
it and that way she can feel it and see
it and read it again and read it again
and read it again it won't be an excuse
thing it won't be uh
well i just did this none of that it's
gonna take full ownership but it's
letting her know i love you and
i'm willing to do what it takes to move
forward are you willing to do what it
takes i don't put words in your mouth
yes sir okay that's that's what i hear
that in your voice um brother i'm proud
of you and you got some hard hard hard
uh
steps to take
and it's gonna get way worse before it
gets better um but i'm proud of you and
you're doing the right thing you're
doing the right thing
holler back at me let me know how this
conversation goes and we will be
thinking about you talk way less than
you think facts are your friends do not
lie
ask her how you can participate in her
healing if she'll have you
and be prepared for this thing to get
way off the rails way off the rails
we'll be right back
hey good folks dr john dolone here all
right we have to talk about sleep when
life gets busy it's the first thing we
neglect we stay up later we binge
another series and we think we can do
everything i know because i've been
guilty of it but you and me and all of
us we have to change we need
sleep sleep is at the core of every
mental physical and relational thing we
do and i found a good night's sleep
starts with a great mattress and that's
why i love dream cloud mattresses and
right now dreamcloud is running their
biggest offer ever just for our
listeners you can get 599 dollars in
accessories plus an additional 250 cash
discount that's a total of
in 849.00 and savings that's pillows a
mattress protector and luxury sheets
it's time to prioritize getting the rest
your body and your mind need because
your mental health matters so go to
or
dreamcloudsleep.com
and enter promo code deloney to get your
new mattress today and enjoy 849 in
savings and accessories
all right we're back let's go out to
kate across the border in ontario what's
up kate
hey dr john thank you so much for taking
my call of course what's up
well i called into the ramsey show in
june and i talked to dave and rachel
during that call some boundary issues i
have with my parents came up and at the
end of that call rachel suggested i dial
up to honey so that's what i'm doing
there it once again i'm bailing out
rachel because i'm just kidding love it
um
yeah i'd love to hear it tell me what's
going on
thank you in 2017 my parents gifted
myself and my husband
a down payment for our home it was very
generous they wanted to bless us fast
forward to april 20 21 we started the
baby steps now we're on baby step 4 and
6.
in december 2021 my grandmother passed
away and left me some money
my mother who's the executor of the
estate asked me what i want to do with
the money i told her my husband and i
would like to use the money to complete
baby step six to pay off her mortgage
she told me
she wants me to use the money for home
repairs and to put into my specific tax
advantage retirement accounts she wants
the money to quote
remain mine in the event of a divorce
she also said that if
we pay off the house with this
inheritance money
quote my father's family will have paid
for almost the whole thing your husband
should pay for half
sounds
sounds like your mom is a huge fan of
your husband
oh you know what and the thing is she
actually loves him so much
did your is your mom divorced did she
get left
no my parents are together i believe my
dad was divorced prior to his
relationship with my mom but i okay
that's i only know that from a passing
conversation that i've heard in
childhood
oh maybe one day
ask your dad that question that'd be
cool to know just where you come from
that seems like
family 101.
um okay let me let me give some uh some
insider baseball to our listeners here
um so
kate is trying to pay off all of her
debts
right um so she found herself did you
have credit cards student loan debt and
all the stuff owned cars loans and all
that kind of stuff
we had a car loan and um
student debt from my husband's doctorate
degree and it was all paid off and we're
so excited okay awesome congratulations
is done sweet so the average listener um
uh listening to this
there is a direct correlation to your
mental well-being and your relational
health and even your physical health and
this idea of safety and the idea of
autonomy if your body knows you're not
safe and the body knows you're not in
control of your life
it will cascade stress hormones through
you all the time and we know from
genetics and we know from behavioral
neurobiology and we know from
experiences people respond in a number
of different ways whether it's anxiety
and depression all these different
things to these stress responses stress
response
and one of the chief stressors of our
time and if you look at a map like a i'm
sorry a graph and you were to chart
the increase of debt in the united
states
over the last hundred years it's it
puddle it puts along puts along and then
it shoots straight up
you could lay over that mental health
diagnostics you could lay over that
all different kinds of of maladies in
our culture and i am convinced in fact
i'm working with some phd students on a
study
so i can i can prove it there is a
direct correlation
direct causal correlation between the
amount you owe on things and your
well-being
and the problem is we live in a culture
that sells debt as a way of being it's
the air we breathe
it also says that um
i don't go down a rabbit hole there so
um
my friend dave ramsey's got a plan how
to get out of debt right here's how you
just do this and here's how you free
yourself and your family and quite
honestly you really do a lot of work on
your mental health and relational health
so that's where kate finds herself
and so what what was the original
like
when you were getting married and your
grandmother was gonna bless y'all with a
house down payment how much was it
my parents um gave us a house down
payment of fifty thousand dollars okay
so your parents gave you 50 grand
and then what's the what's the
inheritance that you've received from
your grandmother
um 166 i've received about half of it
due to just a state red tape i should
receive the remaining half ish in about
a year or in the next year okay
so to the to the listener
there's going to be a debate between
whether do we inherit i mean do we
invest this money so it grows while at
the same time paying mortgage interest
rate and then someone's going to say but
it could grow at ten percent and your
mortgage is only at three percent so
you're actually if you pay your mortgage
off you're being stupid because that
money could earn seven percent you can
earn that gap and blah blah blah
here's what i am hell-bent on on this
show
is solving for freedom
solving for peace
and in my personal life
you can take the seven percent
and set it on fire as far as i'm
concerned because
i don't want to owe anybody anything
because if i don't owe anybody anything
my body goes
and most of us especially our parents
and families have never exhaled because
we've always had a car payment or a
student loan or a home payment and
that's why people get bananas to pay
everything off even if the math might be
different right it might work out
differently
so you are saying kate i
you and your husband are choosing
freedom
not something not some imaginary return
in the market that may or may not happen
down the road right
exactly okay so let me first say if i
was in your seat your situation
i would do exactly the same thing you're
doing 100 to the letter
okay so my advice is not mathematical my
advice is here's what me and my wife
would do in our home
and then what i would do is i would
spend the next 20 years with no house
payment no
car payments no nothing payments
and you want to talk about wealth
accumulation
sister it's going to pile up in a wild
way okay
so
here's the bigger boundary issue um and
i'm i'm gonna be kind of direct with you
okay i don't wanna talk bad about people
that love you and that you love but i'm
gonna be pretty straightforward with you
is that cool i i appreciate the
directness thank you dr john your mom
does not get a vote your grandmother did
not leave your mom a bunch of money with
a few ideas for how she could spend it
she left it to you
and she left it to you because she
trusts you
if you were a drug addict you you were
struggling with addiction you were
struggling with all whatever you
violated your grandmother's values she
would not have put a hundred and sixty
six thousand dollars in your pocket
and say i agree i trust you do with what
you wish
now when it comes to some arbitrary
mathematical whatever she's saying about
your husband is dumb that's just dumb
um here's the reality you've gone all in
with this guy do y'all have kids
no we don't are you gonna have kids
someday or no
no i don't think it's in the cards for
us okay so you're not gonna have kids
so y'all it's just ride or die you too
right
exactly and i love him and they've
they've known him a long time and they
love him too she's just she's very
concerned about
like my personal safety yep and i think
she equates this this money being quote
mine
to my safety gotcha and what i would say
is when you get married this is a very
unpopular man i'm just gonna i'm gonna
get all kinds of great youtube
comments on this one i'm telling you uh
kate don't read the comments on when
this episode comes out
oh no sir if you go it all in with
somebody and you say i'm gonna get
married to you then your stuff is his
stuff
and your cancer diagnosis is y'all's
cancer diagnosis
and your inheritance becomes y'all's
inheritance and his debt becomes y'all's
debt y'all are in this thing together
as a single entity and when you hedge
your
relationships
the big one that i get a lot of grief
for is having separate checking accounts
yes we're gonna make humans together yes
we're gonna we're gonna buy a house
together we're gonna do all these things
but i get my money and he gets his money
that's a hedge because i don't fully
trust him and if you're not all in and
he's not all in
then your marriage is is gonna have it's
gonna have a hole in the boat right the
only way it works is go all in and what
does that mean when you go all in you
know what can happen you can get hurt
really really bad
so i'm also going to be honest with you
there's a chance you pay off this house
and you pay off the mortgage and you'll
pop a bottle of champagne and he files
for divorce the next day
yes that could happen
right that's that could happen it could
it could happen and i i said to her in a
conversation i think
if that did happen you know the next day
or in five years i think the hurt i
would have would not be healed by
half of 160 yeah it wouldn't be healed
by 83 000
yes exactly
yes and yes
and i think that's the other important
thing to remember here is you've got
eighty three thousand dollars so let's
say you take say he takes half
takes half of your house and half of the
retirement half of the whatever you're
still not starving right no
um you'll still have your needs met and
you'll have a
a place where you can grieve because it
would be a mess because not because he
just took your money
but he took your trust in your soul all
these things that hopefully aren't ever
going to happen right
right exactly but following your mom's
logic up the up the trail
the next step is you need to keep
something for you
and the next step is you need to protect
yourself because you might get hurt
and the next step is you shouldn't have
got married in the first place because
that could lead to hurt
and then the next step is you shouldn't
even date because dating might open your
heart and when you open your heart you
can get hurt you see what i'm saying
like if you follow the logic all the way
up there's nowhere to stop
the only place to stop
all in right so
the best
sometimes i give advice here on
situations that i've not experienced um
what i haven't experienced this but i'm
telling you 100 if my wife if if
both of my grandmothers have passed away
if i had gotten a check for 166 000 from
either one of my grandparents it would
have gone directly to paying my house
off
i feel very comfortable with the
financial part of it it's more just the
the relational part that
if and when she asks
what did you do with that
pile of money yeah so i just i here's
the response you don't want an ugly
situation thank you you don't get to
choose the ugly situation she might
and there's not a lot you can do on this
end except be respectful and treat her
with dignity
and say i'm doing what i think is best
for me and my family
if she chooses to throw a temper tantrum
or chooses to act like a child because
she didn't get her way
that's a choice she's made
that's a grenade she's thrown not you
that makes sense
it does make sense and so at the end of
the day i think a wise conversation it
sounds like you and your mom have a
pretty good relationship is that fair
we do we're close we talk lots you know
we have we have disagreements we've had
fights but pretty normal mother-daughter
stuff so don't get sucked into the this
is a math problem conversation because
it's not
this is a mom who loves her daughter
and this is a mom who's either
experienced it or has friends who's
experienced it or watches a lot of
you know late night tv
and
doesn't is
doesn't want her daughter to get hurt
and the fact is you went all in you got
married
and so you
are vulnerable and your husband's
vulnerable and the chance y'all can hurt
each other is real
and the chance you can love each other
and get something better out of your
life than you could have ever imagined
is also real
and so i here's the conversation i would
have or let me just be honest here's a
conversation i have had when me and my
parents have had disagreements
you raised a good son
and you raised me to be thoughtful and
wise and smart and to get seek wise
counsel
trust me with the decision i'm making on
my life
and at least in my life every time my
parents have exhaled and said you're
right
thank you for that that's very
thoughtful and respectful and i think i
think she might respond well to that
yeah and she can give you a hard time
and you can tell her with a smile on
your face if he leaves me
and takes half of everything
i will pay for dinner and i will i will
make a cake that says you were right
and i mean like i will i'll acknowledge
it
i love to bake but i would hope not to
bake that one
[Laughter]
yes that would not be a given um i do
know this is a delicate situation i do
think you are incredibly wise
and i think you are being a great
steward of this money um is my by the
way is my is
is that what dave said to please tell me
i'm right
oh absolutely absolutely okay
yes
um good that's exactly what dave and
rachel said and what dave and george
said in a previous call and i think
again i feel very comfortable with the
financial aspect of the decision
it makes sense i've weighed options but
this is the choice that feels right for
myself and my husband yeah
so
lean into your mom tell her hey you did
a good job you raised a good smart wise
daughter
and i realized that marriage can hurt me
hurt me real bad
and marriage can be incredible too
and um
i'm gonna i'm gonna choose freedom this
time with this incredible gift we're
choosing freedom
and your gift plus um grandma's gift
gives us incredible freedom and now me
and my husband can um
put all of our money towards um giving
all of our money towards saving all of
our money towards
um
joy in our home and in other people's
homes and now we're gonna be free and
maybe for the first time in a generation
we're gonna be free we're gonna be free
we're gonna be free
and um
man what a blessing it's pretty cool
uh
man i hope i have granddaughters like
you
i really do we'll be right back
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at better help betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at
betterhelp.com that's betterhelphelp.com
all right let's go to lisa in hilton
head back to south carolina and the
south hey lisa what's up
hi how are you good sorry i don't know
how to work the phones i'm figuring it
out
how's it going
good good we have a college freshman a
rising college freshman who is due to
move into his dorm in literally two
weeks
and has recently come to us and said he
is not sure
he is ready to go to college yet and
would maybe possibly like to take a
semester to a year off and work instead
um a little background about him is he's
had a full-time job since he graduated
from high school and has loved working
he loves he loves working full-time he
loves making money he's also
a kid that doesn't like changes so
he's always had to be nudged a little to
take risks and do new things and um
i guess my question is my husband and i
really value education and we've we know
that it's much more than just a degree
it's learning to live on your own
learning to live in a dorm with other
people and we want him not to miss out
on that experience
but i guess
we want to know how to support him to
make a good decision without pushing him
in one direction or the other
i love this question lisa so one thanks
for caring enough about your son to be
thinking this way and two thanks for
calling and asking
um i often marvel at my parents i tried
to quit high school athletics when i was
a freshman
and they said no they wouldn't let me
quit
and i got all been out of shape and blah
blah ended up being the greatest
decision ever
things i did this morning
in my like the exercises i did this
morning
um the seeds were planted back when i
was in high school and my little brother
quit when he was a freshman
they let him
i got so mad i was i think i was in
college i think i was a freshman college
like you're letting him quit ridiculous
he was a different kid with different
experiences and different right and they
somehow knew the difference and it was a
great right decision for him
and so um
and he was working out this morning in
the gym too and we right so all i have
to say is this that's a great intuitive
question um
just my gut reaction having worked with
countless college students and countless
college parents
my gut reaction to this situation right
now is
sindhim
and say
um we're gonna give you an off-ramp if
you want it
right okay
um there's something about
um
i'm doing this with my daughter now um
she would prefer she was a covid kid
right so performative years um
preschool kindergarten was all at home
and masked up and so now the world's
back open and it's like hey you gotta
take do an instrument and you're gonna
have to do jiu jitsu or a sport and
she's like i'd rather just sit at home
in color
and so like right so i have to say okay
do this but in three three months we're
gonna give it 90 days and then if you're
done you're done i'm good with that but
i want you to try new things of course
she went to her first piano lesson and
loved every set right so i think you are
right
to say
um we totally hear you
we're going to make you a deal we're not
going to hold it over your head and
we're not going to go bananas if you go
for one semester and say i'm out i can't
do this um we'll check in with you we'll
drive down to wherever school is for um
in one month and 30 days and we'll take
you out to dinner and we're going to get
a pulse on how things are going
right and maybe some some notes on the
calendar along the way that give him
some landmarks
right um that might be real helpful and
maybe he has to do a couple of things
you're going to have to get involved in
one one group
like you have to do one thing right with
one group of wackadoo college students
uh you can't just go in the room and
play halo and then in
september say you hate it you want to
come home
right right maybe he's got to get a job
college college is what you make it so
you can make it great and get involved
and get out of your comfort zone and do
things
and they will you'll look back on those
and those will be the greatest
experiences that you ever had but you
wouldn't have had them had you not
pushed yourself so but let me let me let
me catch you on two things
it was your greatest experience ever
and it might be miserable for him so we
have to hold that loosely right
um sure going to big crazy concerts with
the crowd is all chaotic those are some
of my most formative wonderful memories
my son doesn't like it doesn't like it
that much and i keep saying yeah but if
you just go do it and finally it's like
oh no he's a different right does that
make sense so that's your experience it
was the most formative incredible and
you see other kids have it that doesn't
mean it's his
um the other thing is
um it's college is going to be what you
make of it
is a really intimidating
um
layout for sure it's intimidating
landscape to someone who's had their
school lives curated their home lives
curated their work life's curated
they've never had to make it they don't
have that skill
you know what i'm saying right so it's
like putting somebody in the batter's
box of a major league picture and saying
just swing the bat it's like a ball's
coming 90 miles an hour i don't know
what to do with that right so it can
feel very much that way so when we say
it is going to be what you make of it i
going back to what i said earlier break
it down
once you get involved in one group
i want you to um i'm going to put a
little bit extra money in your account
and i want you once a week you and your
roommate just go hang out go to dinner
on me right
um
in october by october 1 you need to have
a job a part-time job somewhere in the
community
and let's right let's let's get involved
with the film club get involved with the
drama club get involved with the
intramurals or whatever you got to do
one thing sure and right that's
different than it's gonna be what you
make of it i don't even know what that
means right right
okay that's good advice as a high school
kid
everything i was all about making it i
was all about it is gonna be what i make
of it i knew what that meant um other
people that i loved didn't don't have
the skills for that and it's that's fine
i didn't have skills for sitting down
and studying and paying attention
um i was too busy uh having it be what i
made of it
right right
exactly here's a the the
you said something earlier that
oh it's gonna be hard for you and your
husband and this is tough
[Music]
you two value education in a major way
i value education i spent my life doing
it my wife's is a life a lifelong
educator
um
here's here's how much we value it our
son told us for i don't never mind i
don't want to say private stuff
i can just say i looked at my wife and i
was like this is what happens with nerds
raising nerds right um
we value education i also have to know
that my son may come to me one day and
say i want to be a diesel mechanic i'm
going to be the best damn diesel
mechanic that's ever list existed
and i'm gonna take him out to dinner and
say
awesome
right and i have pictures of him playing
frisbee on the lawn at stamford the
chances of that happening are very slim
sure right um and it won't be
intellectual it won't be like his his
brain capacity it's gonna be what his
life wants to look like
um so you guys value it very very much i
would say it might look different it
education just simply looks different in
many corners of the world these days
so don't hold your son hostage to
your dreams are you more so your picture
of what you think his life is going to
look like
right that makes sense and that's so
hard
absolutely yes it is hard because you
want them
of course you want the best for them you
want them to to
do well and
be successful and whatever that looks
like whether it's working or college or
or
what have you but um but here here's the
thing though parents we we don't get
credit for this um and i think i've
talked about this on the show here one
of the
uh if you had to have me distill down
one of the top two or three moments i've
been most proud of my son
he came to me and my wife at christmas
last year
and
said i need to have a family
conversation i think i mentioned on the
show i was like thinking in my head are
you already smoking like really you're
12. right
and he sat us down me and my wife and he
said i would like to ask to not play
baseball this spring but instead i want
to i want to be in the school play i
want to do theater oh
and
yes i i did theater in college my whole
career is based on on acting and theater
i i was like yes
and uh-huh my granddad played baseball
my dad played baseball i played baseball
right and it hit me
oh crap this would be the first spring
we don't do baseball like a delony guys
right and so i had to i had for without
even thinking about it
i had created a world where this is what
our life is going to look like and my 12
year old son bravely sat down and said i
wanted to look like something different
and so it's both and
i as a parent get to grieve the fact
that it's i had a picture and it's going
to be different
right i get that if your son says does a
semester in college and he's and he
makes straight c's and he said guys
right now i'm 18.
this isn't it for me i want to go to
mechanics does he have something else in
mind he wants to do
well he he his passion is film and
writing scripts and um doing uh like
editing and there is a there is a school
out of state
much more out of our budget
and so
that's not really an option right now it
could be down the road if he wants to
work and
match the
you know remaining portion to be able to
go there
um but to be able to go there
immediately out of high school was not
going to be an option and i think there
is some immense value um in
like a screenwriter's gotta learn how to
write
first
right and a
videographer often has to learn what a
story is and what an arc is and take a
psychology class in a counseling class
and be around wackadoo people and how to
manage artists right all those things
so i would tell you a and by the way you
can't afford it so that is what it is
right
i think there's a way
whether there's a film major or a way to
be involved in that
to get into your local theater program
there's a way to get into your local
fill in the blanks right right there's a
way to get that experience
while also
getting your feet underneath you
yeah as a freshman in college right so
it's not an either or is what i'm saying
um yes
and it sounds like based on what you
told me about him it sounds like
he's just getting really cold feet and
he's got a got another idea
right right yes i think i think the fact
that he's enjoyed working and the fact
that he likes making money and he knows
what his goal is as far as careers down
the road
he's kind of thought well i don't want
to waste your money and go into
this school when maybe i should just go
and save my money until i can go to the
other school but we told them
you know get your degree or at least get
two years under your belt
at the in-state you know more affordable
school and then you can re-evaluate you
know from there yeah i'm a big believer
and i get some pushback on this i got
colleagues that disagree with me that's
fine that's totally fine
um
i don't believe
in the phrase those
that education was wasted
right um people often tell me like i was
so stupid i got a degree in teaching and
now i do this as such a waste and i tell
him it was not a waste right i agree 100
with that yes even if it was finding out
if you if you told somebody hey it's
going to cost you this much money
to find out something that you never
ever ever want to be a part of
and sometimes that's a good investment
right right sure because i spent a lot
of money chasing things that i'm like i
wish i i wasn't doing that all to say
right
often the idea of that was a waste of
time as a waste of money is a is a frame
of mind
right my first phd in education was
absolutely i'm not doing it i'm not
using it at all
and it was one of the most valuable
experiences of my life
right right and so it's it's just yeah
it's it's it's essentially priceless
you're exactly right but i could also
say what a waste of time what a waste of
money that was so stupid it wasn't um
right but i'm not i'm not technically
using it but i'm using it every second
of every day right all i have to say is
you know that i'm just i'm that's more
for the listener
um and i do have a immense bias towards
education i do um and there's there's a
truth there so you're calling me ask my
opinion i am biased um i also have
worked with
thousands of 18 year olds
and man they get nervous they get scared
and they think
right and i think
parental wisdom especially not
parental insane demands and parental
rights you're going to be a lawyer
because it's going to make me feel right
that's not what you're doing yeah you're
saying i know my kid you need to go
ahead and do this
yeah right yeah and i think that's a lot
that's great advice with with a
um circling back to the very beginning
let's put some markers on a piece of
paper we're gonna come visit you on this
day and this day and this day you're
gonna have to let us know a group you've
joined by this day
um if you are in the film club or in the
theater department or whatever we're
going to come see you um whatever
productions you do um and you and your
husband like hey we got a budget for
this and figure this out because we're
going to go be involved here and
you come home at christmas and sit down
and write us a three-page essay on why
this isn't for you we're going to read
it we're taking you out to a fancy
dinner and then we're going to go look
at other schools we're going to go look
at other things perfect does that make
sense it's a perfect plan yes absolutely
thank you for that you're so great lisa
you're so wisdom i appreciate it he is
lucky lucky to have you parents all
parents
listening it is
so okay it's not it matters okay it's
right it's good to have a vision a
picture of your kid's life
it's also good and right to say i know
you don't quote unquote feel like doing
this i'm your parent this is what we're
doing right now
and it's also wise and good to give your
kids choices and options and exit
strategies
we often make them either or
either i go to film school or i do this
uh
i want you to try this
i want you to practice this i want you
to lean into this be curious about this
i'm gonna foot the bill i'm gonna help
out and if it doesn't work
i'm going to high five you we're going
to throw a party and then we're going to
turn left and then we're going to turn
right
but i want you to have these experiences
and i'm your parent and that's my job is
to be wise and to continue to speak into
your life there's a reason why
culturally
all across the world
there's not a mad release of 18 year
olds into the world
there is mandatory military service
there is additional education
there is a
a
time a natural time when there is begins
to be a separation where somebody begins
to find their adult footing
it doesn't have to be college it doesn't
have to be a four year university it
doesn't have to be an ivy league school
absolutely not
um it can be a i'm taking a year and in
this year i'm just going to work man i'm
18. i'm just going to work at mcdonald's
i'm going to work down the street i'm
going to get my feet under me i'm going
to learn some skills i'm going to learn
some tasks and mom and dad i'm going to
be hyper intentional we're going to go
to lunch once a week and we're going to
just talk about how you're developing it
growing going to read some books
together we're going to do some
developmental things or you're going
straight to the military you're going to
learn some discipline you're going to
learn under the wisdom and tutelage and
experiences of other adults in your life
but this idea that you turn 18 you're
free to run the world it's not safe it's
not smart and it doesn't make any sense
and culturally for bajillions of years
we've
we've understood this innately
and over the last 15 20 years we've just
said hey do whatever you want to
whatever feels good and this also works
in reverse by the way some kid says i'm
going to mit i'm going to mit i'm going
in my tea there comes a moment as a
parent and you look at your kid and say
i know you you're not
or if you want to pay for it you can
walk out the front door i can't keep you
from doing it but it's not wise for you
the wisest choice for you is x and y and
there's all these stories of the kids
they're like i'm doing it anyway and
they go on and start a company and make
a billion dollars there's a million of
those
i've set with there's a few of those
i've sat with countless folks
countless over the years in my office
behind closed doors
heartbroken young people heartbroken
parents who tried to force a thing that
wasn't forcible
all i'd say is be intense with your kid
have them try things and also give them
off ramps most importantly be
intentional be intentional be
intentional we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up or you can share
hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
thanks for being with us uh man i just
walked in i got the best guitarist i've
ever seen i've never actually seen him
that i that i know
but secretly he's a shredder but man his
favorite band ever is good charlotte he
loves him he knows all the charlotte
songs i don't think that's true
but we're going to go with it just as a
crew
in his favorite uh good charlotte song
he actually has his tattooed on his
chest it just if he takes his shirt off
which he does all the time just right
across the top of it it says the anthem
so this is his favorite song tattooed on
his body songs the anthem and it goes
like this it's a new day but it feels
old and it's a good life that's what i'm
told but everything it all just feels
the same at my high school it felt more
to me like a jail cell a penitentiary my
time spent there only made me see that i
don't ever want to be like you
i don't wanna do the things you do i'm
never gonna hear the words you say and i
don't ever wanna
i don't ever wanna be like you don't
wanna be just like you what i'm saying
is this is the anthem throw all your
hands up you i don't want to be you
[Music]
it's kind of heavy
i didn't expect that coming i thought
good charlotte was like a happy band
we'll see you soon